so this CNBC story as stocks have become
mighty volatile long-term investors
could be induced to become more
short-term oriented in their thinking
buying stocks on a single day's rally or
selling after a swift 11% decline such
as we saw last week based on the
historical performance of the S&P 500
it's that second decision the fear-based
moved to sell that is the more dangerous
one let me try that again so make sure
you hear that based on the historical
performance of the S&P 500
it's the second decision the fear-based
moved to sell that is the more dangerous
one in fact even if one was the world's
worst market timer over the past several
decades one still made money on stocks
according to an analysis done by
institutional portfolio manager and
financial writer Ben Carlson he names
his awful or perhaps unlucky investor
Bob hypothetically Bob made his first
investment in the beginning of 1973
right before a 48% crash of the market
the S&P 500 he bought his high Z goodbye
it dropped almost in half this is me
some rosy Bob then held on to the stocks
after the drop saving a total of forty
six thousand dollars and not getting up
the gumption to commit anymore savings
until again he bought in September of
1987 right before a 34% crash Bob then
continued to hold tight making only two
more investments before retirement which
came right before the 2000 crash and
then the 2007 crash so how did Bob do
with our hypothetical investment after
these 42 years of epic market misfortune
he bought at the fore he bought right
before the four largest drops in the
market the four worst times since 1972
by now I'm summarizing okay so he mate
so how do you do
well he made money and if I
a lot of money as the market
successfully made record highs Bob
turned the 184 thousand dollars that he
invested on those four events just at
those four events six thousand and
nineteen seventy three forty six
thousand and nineteen eighty seven sixty
eight thousand and two thousand sixty
four thousand and two thousand seven one
hundred eighty four thousand turned into
one million one hundred and sixty
thousand dollars for a total profit of
980 thousand dollars that represents an
annualized return of roughly nine
percent on a money weighted basis even
after accounting for inflation Baba's
increases wealth substantially by
investing in stocks and never selling
the key is is that Bob never ever sold
his holdings instead of riding the stock
market's long term trend higher instead
he rode the trend higher this
hypothetical analysis reveals that it is
critical to really understand your time
horizon and that you need to think long
term if one's investing horizon is
several decades long then the stock
market has proven to be an extremely
good bet provided one didn't attempt to
be smart by jumping out when one
believes downside is ahead what would be
interesting to lose and overlay folks of
this particular article in this piece of
data let me recap in our hypothetical
investor Bob put in one hundred eighty
four thousand at four different times a
total of one hundred eighty four
thousand four different times the four
he invested the day before at the
highest point though four worst crashes
since 1970 and 184,000 turned into one
million one hundred and sixty thousand
dollars so he made about a million
dollars but he never sold I mean think
if you had bought on September the 10th
before nine one one by the way that
wasn't one of the worst crashes on the
day the market opened back up after nine
one one think about that
what if you bought that day how freaked
out would you be you bought it a high
the market dropped substantially but it
didn't drop I mean and dropped as far as
these for this guy doing this analysis
picked the worst for possible downturns
and you invest the day before that if
you don't pull out you don't get hurt
those that don't jump off a roller
coaster don't get hurt and they get the
thrill of the ride so I guess the
markets down again today it could be up
again today I don't know which it is you
know I don't think I care and I'd like
to do an overlay of all the
end-of-the-world predictions that go
with these people trying to get you to
do stupid but things like take all your
money out and put it in gold then you
would see the real stupidity of this
over an extreme period of time